the old ex-girlfriend judy foster jane
foster thor love and thunder is very
different from the thor films that came
before it but whether or not you're a
fan of this addition to the thor
universe you've gotta love all the
behind the scenes footage let's check
out all the details from thor love and
thunder that didn't make it to the big
screen number one laugh attack taika
on this set taika waititi often couldn't
hold in his laughter if you're an actor
a surefire way to know that your
performance is comedy gold is if your
director can't stop laughing long enough
for you to get through a take
well luckily for the cast of thor 11
thunder director taika waititi made it
very clear that this movie has one funny
cast
according to thor himself chris
hemsworth many takes were interrupted by
tyka's infectious laughter
number two superhero sing-along
superheroes love to sing too if tyka's
fits of laughter didn't make it clear
enough that he's far from a tough
no-nonsense director just wait until you
hear his onset singing in some hilarious
behind-the-scenes footage taika lets his
apparent title as david bowie's number
one fan take over his title as director
and chris hemsworth and the cast and
crew couldn't help but get into it and
make it a full-on sing-along
number three dynamic duo taika and chris
make the ultimate dynamic duo while he
may have been thor 11 thunder's biggest
goofball tycho wasn't the only class
clown among the cast he had a partner in
crime chris hemsworth when this
hilarious pair took entertainment
tonight around the set it was obvious
that these two are totally on the same
page when it comes to both their art and
their jokes
number four genius child
chris calls taika a genius child but
tyga and chris aren't just onset bffs
chris also has the utmost respect for
his director in an interview chris
describes tyka as kind of like a genius
child and says that his big kid style
allows him to have unmatched imagination
and creativity number five tessa's
flinch
did anyone else catch valkyrie's little
flinch in this scene
well it turns out even the pros aren't
immune to editing errors in this video
for vanity fair tessa thompson who
reprises her role as valkyrie for the
third time in thor 11 thunder brings a
little error to tyka's attention don't
worry taika we didn't catch it either
number 6 how to be thor
chris hemsworth taught his instagram
followers how to be thor let's guess
step one get a magical hammer step two
get really really buff according to thor
himself that may not be so far off just
after thor eleven thunder premiered
chris hemsworth posted this video on his
instagram account
if only becoming a superhero really was
as easy as this guy makes it look number
7. wild chris
chris hemsworth howled like a wolf
behind the scenes okay things were
seriously getting wild on this set we
all know that dogs hate thunderstorms so
why would chris hemsworth transform into
a wolf for a movie called
love and thunder we have no idea what
caused chris to give in to his wolf-like
instincts but a behind-the-scenes clip
shows him howling like a wolf on set
number eight hammer or golf club chris
traded in his hammer for a golf club and
a hilarious dance on instagram thor
leaven thunder didn't just bring out
thor's animal side it also definitely
brought out his silly side and chris
hemsworth is not afraid to show that
silly side to the world
amidst all the promotion for the movie
hemsworth posted this totally goofy
video of him dancing while golfing on
instagram whoever said gods can't dance
number nine defying gravity a behind the
scenes clip shows how the actors defied
gravity for the movie with a degree from
harvard an academy award and a major
role in the marvel cinematic universe is
there anything natalie portman can't do
all it takes is a little movie magic to
make jane foster airborne portman
actually needed someone holding her up
off camera to make this scene a reality
number 10. cast wide screams
we've seen a cast-wide sing-along and
now we've got a cast-wide scream along
yeah seems like this whole cast love
making lots of noise whenever the
cameras stopped rolling there are clips
of various cast members letting loose
and letting out a good old cathartic
scream between takes and according to
christian bale who plays the crazy
creepy villain gore the godbutcher this
movie's screams weren't only for behind
the scenes moments in an interview
christian says that one of his favorite
moments in the film turned out to be
designated for the blooper reel as i
just kind of screamed for sort of 30
seconds straight marvel went no and who
does christian say was screaming right
along with him
surprising to no one it was director
taika watiti seriously after hearing all
this who wouldn't want to be in
taikawati's next movie his sets are like
the best parties in hollywood
number 11
high tensions
i have to go and help pick up the
spirits with my bubbly energetic
personality
speaking of partying on set is it true
that all that partying and goofing off
happened as a result of a tense work
environment we're gonna say a hard note
to that one in this behind the scenes
moment taika wetiti jokes about the high
tensions and bad morale on set while
filming and how he's going to cheer the
cast up even so it's very clear that the
cast is feeling anything but tense
though we're sure tyke is still
lightened in already light mood with his
jokes and general goofiness
number 12 cgi regrets taiko watidi does
have a regret about some of the cgi
while the actors can be goofy once in a
while the cgi really shouldn't be on
their episode of vanity fair's notes on
a scene series taika watiti and tessa
thompson went into a lot of detail
breaking down that taste of the rainbow
scene does that look real
in that particular shot no actually
in fact according to tessa all of the
characters in this clip look a little
less real than they'd like they may not
have loved the way this on-screen moment
turned out for the movie but it
definitely made for a funny off-screen
moment for us fans
number 13 continuity error
and if you're a fan of tiny errors that
made it past the final edit we've got
another one for you eagle-eyed fans
spotted a continuity error in the form
of a hole in thor's robe right before
his quick change into his 80s rocker
outfit
we wish we could have seen taika and
tessa's reaction to seeing that for the
first time it was almost certainly all
giggles number 14
filming at best buy
there's one scene that's one of the most
beautifully scenes i've seen on film
that we shot at the best by parking lot
the only way we thought we'd see thor in
a best buy was on the front of an old
dvd case according to natalie portman
though thor and her character jane
foster were both way closer to a best
buy than you'd ever expect to see them
every time you said i'm like that's the
best my parking
and while she loves how the scene turned
out she can't seem to forget that thor
was swinging that famous hammer right
where a geek squad car was probably
parked
number 15. world's best dad
it turns out chris hemsworth isn't just
one of the world's favorite superheroes
and a totally fun goofball to have
around on set he's also an amazing dad
just a few days after the 11 thunder
premiere chris shared a super sweet
instagram shout out to the person he
calls his favorite superhero his
daughter india rose he shared two photos
of him and his daughter the first
picture was taken 11 years ago when she
was just a baby during her first time on
set and the second shows a much more
grown up india rose on the set of thor
love and thunder now that's some serious
thor love without the thunder
have you seen thor love and thunder yet
was seeing the movie as much fun as
making it seem to be tell us your
thoughts in the comments and remember to
like and subscribe to the things for all
of your movie and tv needs